okay for people who are joining this
livestream we haven't been having so
many of these live streams of late for
two reasons one because version 12.1 is
getting wrapped up and there's lots of
bug fixes going on and two because I've
been off not fishing but fizzing doing
physics working very intensely on that
actually recording a lot of screen
captures which will release when we're
ready to launch the whole project um but
so this is a rare language development
meeting that we're having right now and
let's get started being reminded we are
almost at the 500 hour mark for live
streams that we've done as part of this
program
alright let's start off with spliced so
this is something we have discussed and
we have already an implementation in c
unfortunately we don't have an
experiment for some time so this is
external but I don't think you can use
it if any way we can slide it into 12
one I think we can if we find a name we
can great that will be great partly
because and this is a very rageous thing
but the that would help to make the
potential universe tweetable interesting
I think it fits I think it's it
currently the well I don't know we don't
have real candidates but 141 characters
is one pretty good one okay so we know
we're not going to worry about that
that's that's a kind of piece of
connectivity of the world of having the
university tweetable I don't think we're
gonna worry about um okay
represents an elements of a list that
will automatically be why don't we say
something like be spliced into the list
as a sequence of elements because you
don't have the list to refer to really a
list what amount must be spliced into an
outer list into a surrounding list
represents what do we say for nothing
well that could be removed
well that's what we should say what why
did we not why did we say
oh represents an element of a list I see
represents down into a list
you
I really would like to get the word
spliced in there
hi Howie should make this bigger sorry
guys
so the only other candidate name for
this is peeled
I like unpeeled honestly but getting
back to spiced how about there will
automatically be spiced into any
surrounding list
you
you
you
well represents an expression that will
automatically be spliced into any
surrounding list as the sequence of
elements sure any list in which it
appears okay well so fine
actually better in a sense because it
doesn't imply you could nest with some
had other than list yes
um we need to say something about as
part of as removed as part of the
standard evaluation process right yes
indeed because this is implemented yeah
resolved as part of okay let's take a
look at some examples here I wish I
could run it so the example that I found
most useful is subset replace and if I
do a subset replace into some list you
know
well let's just do we could just do a
subset replace into the list on two
three four five and then we say in the
subset replace we say X blank Y blank
arrow spliced
of ABC you see what I'm saying yes do we
like the way that looks I mean do we do
we think that's a you know we've we've
messed around with this name many times
but to me okay let's read what that
would say so we're doing subset replace
X Y does that read correctly a clearer
case in which had problems was the
second example I was trying to say
surprised expressions do not splice but
then I thought well it says spliced as
if it is already spliced and that's why
I chance to order flooding I think we
should say automatically flatten to meet
where's the see also if I might say so
the very most obvious see also here is
flooding flatten and flatten at I think
we should also mention catenate since
that's my favorite bug is using flatten
instead of catenate no it's way we use
crush a sub sub list where you don't
mean to alright let's take a look at
this flattened that list of elements
inside another well splice a list of
elements into another list no no insert
a list of our put and put a list of
elements puttin a list of elements
include a list of elements that are too
including those developments to be
spliced that's awkward
also you're doing contortions to avoid
using the term sequence instead of list
the first list I see I'm not really okay
at least in scientists placed yeah but
it's we're treating it as a sequence no
I know that but but you're including a
list of elements to be spliced into a
surrounding list well would then include
etc to be sliced I don't know this just
strikes me as awkward grammatically
awkward well that's the question is is
it chromatic really because they have
the wrong name that's what we're not so
worried about the actual text here so
yeah same here
okay give a list of elements to be
spliced into a surrounding list dad I'm
okay with okay but so does that read
correctly to be spliced into a
surrounding list okay the problem is it
is is a different form than for example
nothing which just the nothing we say
what was wrong with splice elements list
or sequence into a surrounding list
sorry I'm sorry what are you saying I
specify a list of elements I don't care
about that text what we what we care
about is whether the name of this
function is right and we're trying to
determine that by figuring out whether
we can write sentences that involve it
that make any sense well I think we can
in this case it's just not that if I
didn't do it okay
um me the thing is that it looks as if
it is in past tense well it's the thing
to be done later yeah yeah there's that
well I think the I believe it was the
originals
whatever into a surrounding list Indus
Conda but the whole point is we're
trying to explain the past tense use
here this is by using the term to be
spliced right that that's my point and
the question is does that work or is it
that the spliced name for the function
is wrong okay the question is if you see
a piece of code do you understand what
it does well yeah but I'm condition - no
no I understand that but I'm asking
other people perhaps in this meeting um
I don't think it's terrible I think if
you see this and it's um I mean I find
this a little bit less of obvious -
spliced ABC I mean it's better than
peeled peeled is just utterly obscure
yield is something where you'd have to
know the the kind of analogy we have
also I was looking for other functions
we have spliced distribution I don't
know whether that's resonant in any
sense display of distribution yes the
heck is it it's it's a distribution that
is specified by by my chunks yeah I
wouldn't worry about that I don't think
anybody other than auto-completion will
be bothered the finer the normal body in
a Pareto tale okay so that is a
distribution that has been spliced
together well it's not bad it's a
similar sense yes all right let's do it
let's do it let's call it spliced and
let's put it in
we should target experimental but I hope
it isn't so it accepts inside like
sparse arrays and things like that so
the outer the outer list needs to be a
list but internal it can be any type of
array is that okay
does it make any sense in a sparse array
to insert it into a sparse array I don't
think that makes a lot yes it'll be
normal fide no I understand but in a in
a into a sparse array oh yeah no there
is not that would be bad and actually
nothing breaks sparse right okay there
is the question of spliced and nothing
and associations but that's not an issue
for today I mean the question is what we
could imagine splicing essentially a
packet I think it's obscure no that's
not gonna work because an association
requires a particular structure yeah
yeah this is not the tool for structured
arrays of any type right have a comment
on livestream which I don't fully
understand about compatible with Norfolk
operations for this but this is this is
something this is nothing C's this this
is just a thing for taking this is an a
symbolic in a most way to insert things
and lists there are plenty of ways to
insert things in lists if you're doing
it from the outside but the whole point
of this is to have a a payload that
explodes on contact and inserts itself
into a list I have a question more for
Jose at the moment cuz I don't remember
the code does this work with set art I'm
guessing it does not oh that's an
interesting question
in other words if you say something like
this ABCD and then you say this of three
Ypres right right what
what the heck does it do no I don't
expect that to work okay III think it
should it would just show up as an
explicit sliced and tough luck
exactly I can imagine that evaluating TT
then glue the splice right but it won't
it won't feed it into the the downrod
the own value of TT will contain a naked
spliced which i think is better than the
situation we have now with sequence what
the sequence do it you don't see it I
mean yes if you look at the own value
but you you will think from the output
that you have if you reset the third
element of the list after you do TT of
three is spliced you reset TT of three
it will reset the whole spliced right
the first element right and if you were
to just say yo enter TT and shift enter
you would see the explicit spliced I
think no you wouldn't because by the
time it you get it out it will you're
right your and it will have spliced
itself yeah okay so it's gonna be as
mysterious a sequence in that respect
but it yeah okay how would you see it
you would see it if you did question
mark TT you would see it right but isn't
that the same with sequence I think so I
think but sequence has the insanity that
it is Auto splicing inside other
expressions and lists so that when you
say TT of three equals a sequence it's
going to write you know well it's cause
of confusion including some recently
here in house say this whole sequence
but for example if is not so people
write very frequently if condition comma
sequence at at list empty list which is
so ugly yeah we don't document whole
sequence no we don't that's just an
internal thing right no and we do I
think it's it's an attribute or is it C
control sequence work sorry
so that is signal fault but if is not so
if you want to do condition to insert a
sequence people have to do this very
strange things so I don't forget let's
put that in before we forget it let's
put let's reference sequence hold let's
let's reference this to two spliced and
obviously we also want to do that with
sorry let me let me put another thing in
here in addition to this we probably
want to put insert in here yes list
really relevant because it's something
into yeah sort of those okay because
insert will auto splice right um okay do
you want to since we're okay we can put
it into insert okay so we we really want
to put that it's probably before flatten
out or is it before by before sequence
here I think this is gonna be a nice
piece of functionality Oh another thing
is replaced part is that relevant to
this no it's not because replaced part
won't do this only insert does this
and we want to insert that before I'm
sorry it's so small here guys I'll make
it bigger
um that's okay and we'll insert them
flatten and flatten at okay do you want
to figure out what page this goes on to
that's that's some what guide page it
goes into um and don't forget to give it
to Raj for the new features listen it's
coming in late we have a list operations
page don't we I thought so
structural operations on list something
like that yeah but where it where do we
have nothing my friendly elephant thing
properly speaking can one have nothing
we've made these jokes too many times
okay so here now there it is
so I think we want to put it into into
here and we got bunch of background
noise here
from lists give sequences of elements
sequence of elements and to list okay
you have to be be a spliced I think it's
okay um okay now we also have structural
rearranging and restructuring lists I
would prefer to put spliced instead of
sequence in here cut out both yeah we
could have both but spliced first I
think we should put spliced in here and
not sequence I think sequence is just a
hack this is gonna confuse everybody as
far as I can tell though it's behavior
is very similar to spliced except
spliced only applies to an outer ambient
list that is correct
maybe we should say that here dude I
mean the second node is trying to
converse spliced on sequence oh you
already have it sure has me good okay
all right I think that that's that let's
go on to the next item fold while she
tries web page of fold while we are we
serious about getting in I've already
forgotten so let's see fold while well
needs some work and and the design is
not so trivial
so the our problem here was that by
default this function returns the first
case that fails and not the last that
let's remind ourselves many examples
what it actually does
okay fold while divided by factor a
range of 10
so keep folding in division on fire I
mean it would be is there a fold well
list as well yes yes yeah they'll be
less obscure than this one okay so fold
while list is dividing starting with 5
factorial
notice that the fold I see that this
could never this always has to have a
starting condition true this is 3
argument form that omits the starting
condition that probably should be yes
yes yeah there is it's just the first
element of list if not otherwise
specified so fine so then this so fold
well list until integer Q fails why does
it return the 1/6 yes right so that's
the thing we have discussed a number of
times and we have the precedent of nest
while nest while list does that too so
the way to avoid these is by an
additional argument that allows you to
give more or less argument so we can say
give me one less by the way I'm sorry
just commenting on comments on the live
stream the reason of parent reducing
spliced is because it is similar to
sequence which we've had for ever and
ever I have never been happy with
sequence because it is very undefined
because it's very dangerous you sequence
will explode on contact with any
function and that's very awkward spliced
is built to be only deal with lists
which makes it completely safe and
that's why we have it and that's why you
know we've had this problem for like 30
years of having you know
hackie code written with sequence this
avoids that hacky code and should
sequence exist yes it's necessary for it
to exist for low-level operations but
this is the user level thing that we
want people to use you can consider it
semantic sugar not syntactic sugar the
hacky so-called reason that we still
absolutely want sequence for top-level
use is for VAR args things like find
minimum etc well know know what sequence
is is what x double blank matches to
what X double blank when you say f of X
double blank equals you know whatever it
equals the actual value found 2x is a
sequence which is then spliced right
that's an operation that happens outside
of evaluation that's an operation that
happens in you know pattern matching
resolution which is a different thing
than evaluation sure the place where we
get into trouble is the interaction
between sequence and evaluation I'm only
claiming we still need it oh yeah we do
I mean even ordinary external users know
I agree but but we need it
I mean also it's the binding of hash
hash right I mean it's it's the binding
of things that automatically splice
themselves in to things in general but
the the thing that I think is probably
wrong is that sequence auto splices
aren't evaluation arguably it should
only auto splice on you know bound
variable resolution and things like that
you see what I'm saying yeah I'm not
sure I agree though doesn't matter but
we're thirty years too late anyway okay
um I mean and you you win pragmatically
so to speak um okay let's look at fold
well lists okay so you're claiming that
nest while you say that nest while
returns the first failure case yes it
does so this design follows very closely
that of this one but what does wile do
well doesn't return the first failure
case does it no we have no and for
example take while does not do that
either but this is a lot closer to nest
Y right
why did we make nests well return the
failure case it's the simplest thing
because imagine that you have a seed
that fails already a little something
okay but what about nest well list does
it also return the failure case yeah yes
because we have these alignment it can
it has to return the last thing that
nest while would return quiet plus
whatever before right I mean the basic
problem is that nest while I mean in the
most extreme and ridiculous case nest
well could return nothing could have
returned nothing in the case where it
failed the first case they could have
but didn't correct something we should
remember as a paradigm for things like
that because we we we agonized about
what could it return the consistent
thing for it to return because it means
that it's a list if it was in a list
drat
I wish we done that um it could have
returned sequence I'd say you know
pinned whatever function it's inserted
in but something just simple peek does
that become return our signals if it if
it really yes go pick is a bit of a
disaster I have using pick recently my
use case for pick is the following I I'm
doing a big parallel computation I've
got a big list of elements big list of
things I want to I can't do parallel
select because that requires that's not
an embarrassingly parallel operation so
to speak it select would require so what
I do is I do a parallel map across this
across all the elements and then I get
back a true/false list and then I say
pick the elements with the true/false
list that works no no are you I just I
believe it has was not thought out fully
for case of nested lists matrices etc
that's my baby
not very well
there's bug reports somewhere in there I
thought it was only one level thing
well that was news to me no it's
supposed to work on deeper cases but the
lecture can be deeper that's crazy yeah
and it doesn't do it very well I do
remember that what the problem is right
now but I think in the possible issues
there is an example with sequence well
he just passed at the top there middle
right by your arrow what what is that
what is that doing
I thought pick only worked on lists I
understand why isn't this just returning
a null list I don't understand this at
all this returns those elements of the
first thing oh I see this is a false
that's a top level false that's crazy
that's completely crazy yeah well
nobody's ever gonna use this case which
is good because this case is crazy yes
but if you have something like and
matrix in the first argument and at
least in the second you have similar
situations so it's less crazy but I'm er
not very well
yep if you all have to pardon me while I
pop open this can of worms in the middle
of a meeting
yeah let's not let's not do this this is
an LCC discussion for the future
sometime I mean this should have been
defined only for one level I don't know
why it was generalized like that how old
is this 2004 okay alright fold well list
yeah so the way this is solved in nest
list is by adding the final three
arguments actually the last one is
important right the cut that describes
what it's gonna do in certain cases the
what the default cases and things so it
tells you to go farther or additional
results or fewer results so in our case
if you just want the previous one just a
minus one again so what happens if you
get fewer if there are fewer that come
out then exist so to speak right now
it's implemented as an up to sort of
thing so in other words return the last
one possible but what if there are none
to return good questions sit in there I
think I think it returns the default
initial element I think but but but you
could tell it I see for an extra end
times I see so that's parameterizing
this behavior so the question is the
default value of n for value of n is
zero
yes what if the pilot well what if n was
minus one we could make that the default
that's that's the other really the only
other competing possibility right there
in that case the only I mean we could
have a different default between nest I
know that's completely crazy sorry
between nest wildin last well list
that's completely crazy but the case
where if that was minus one
still have the case where you have to
return nothing right
but the good news is we do actually have
something to return now you just you did
just say nothing is something didn't you
something okay just to confirm right
I'll have it yeah I'll have it return
nothing I mean if that's what we're
agreed on which have which return
nothing
now I've falled wild not nest while I'm
not touching that no it doesn't seem
consistent with nest while now then I
gotta go trampling on someone else's
garden I don't think we can change okay
we'll provide these arguments starts
with X button repeatedly applies F until
applying tested result no longer yields
true you see if this had been nest until
yeah I was a sink in there but then it's
sort of a nest until not or nests
something like oh this isn't this nest
while it's a nest until not yeah then oh
it isn't even that it's not just until
not true yeah keep dividing Mike
until the results is no longer an even
number so there is the example
I mean by the way that's not a useless
case where it where it keeps going right
I mean the argument for what it's doing
here
if correctly documented is you've
already done the look ahead you see what
I'm saying you've already tried it why
not return it it's not like you don't
try it that it says up now I'm not gonna
go there I'm gonna just return this it
already tried it trouble is that while
oh boy let's think about this so while
condition I mean while is operating as a
side effect okay
well take well has the has the advantage
that it has an outer wrapper which could
have nothing in it yeah well take well
will be completely crazy to give an
element where it isn't true yeah yeah
you can run off the end of the list
there
right but also nobody would expect take
while
well okay all right so if we have to
keep the stopping condition of fold
while list consistent with nest while
then what are the questions that remain
here well this is in comparison to nest
while list that takes three additional
arguments so we are taking two of them
the other one is a maximum condition but
here because we have the length of the
list in the document we don't we don't
have a max right and then they the other
additional argument M the next last
that's useful to perform comparisons
with the previous result yes how many
previous ones to compare with exactly
because for example you may want to
compare whether they are equal stop when
when two of them are different or equal
since they're yes so these are things
that have been added in this one least
not intake while or while itself but but
they seem useful I agree and it's a
possibility that some of those would be
worth adding and take while I mean
actually take while one thing that I've
wanted many times is find me the that's
a different operation finally the
running maximum keep get get get me a
sequence of running Maxima so to speak
in a list yeah I mean maybe fold while
there's a way to go about that but no it
doesn't I don't think it is I think I
think the the running Maxima one way to
do it is just to do a fold how does that
work would that work actually that's a
cute way to do it if I have um something
like this and I say fold of Max over
that list now full old list of Max over
that list and then I simply say split
that or delete duplicates that's clever
I never thought of that before I've
needed this operation so many times and
I think we put we put that in a oh
that's cool that's nice that's a piece
of like poetic code um and with
difference this Prada we can find their
positions as one with differences in
this implicit how because with the ones
that are not differences difference the
zeros are the non positions right things
that are not zeros more transitions
except zero here and and you get the
positions where you're saying that the
things that accept zero yeah yeah that's
cool that's very nice it's good examples
that's actually a nice example of I
don't know what functional programming
or something I don't know what kind of
programming um might be a fun thing to
put on the both the fold list
can we put that on the fold list page
and it seems like a nice application
thing what's that okay but a question on
the live stream about where the take
well can be compiled I do not know the
answer to that if it can't now it must
be very close to being able to be um
okay so fold well list what happens to
the version of this where there isn't an
X oh I see we can do that in this case
yeah all right that's not ambiguous
yeah that's not ambiguous the three
argument case is not ambiguous but I
think I'm you're gonna add the M in the
end I think they actually all end up
being unambiguous you can always sort
out which you're dealing with by whether
you have have or don't have right okay
are there any other questions about fold
well well list and one more which is
about operator forms so I think I have
in the patient for while so two cases
yeah cases at the end can be done I
don't think we can do more than that so
we have an operator form fold we do but
for example we don't have operator forms
for next while because it's another
complicated function with many arguments
I mean that's cute that we can do this
by the way i I just want to bring up
some in terms of operator forms the form
triple at which I use a lot right
doesn't have an operator form because it
isn't an operator so to speak I mean
that there is no word for this right
that would be I can't say apply F it's
apply F at level one right right
but there isn't there isn't an operator
form you know you know apply top or
something of F that is the pure operator
form that is I mean what I have to write
is F triple at I mean I write this is
I've got tons of code that looks like
that
I mean roughly you have an in fix where
two are again fix for something that
doesn't have a pure prefix that's right
well we can do these with separate or
apply it with the permutation you're
saying you'd say operator applied yeah
all apply which is 1 3 this is not
simpler doing now then we have a curried
form like this no no we would have s + 1
F 1 like that yes you're serious here ok
and then I put this in but you could
it's a 3-2 permutation is 1 C 2 no
that's horrifying
okay great so I mean I would prefer to
use F triple that hash sign but it's
just you know that's I think we should
put it on the agenda to consider the
possibility of having an actual name for
this triple outside thing okay we should
just allow adding more ads to change the
level we do something like that with
percents I'm joking
I don't have done this comment on our
live stream but nest while and nest well
list they do different things they're
not there's no polymorphism problem they
take all kinds of different stuff they
just don't they handle absolutely
generic data structures they just they
do different things
they um Oh someone's pointing out but I
can just say moving map of max onto this
oops I need more arguments what does
moving map why does moving map needed to
size W why does moving map not assume
that it is everything well that's
interesting maybe it wants a two there
I'm just guessing why would it want a to
how many things to compare but that's
not kind of give the right answer is it
I don't know no I don't think so
oh because you lose the first one no
well it's doing is it's doing in buckets
of two I mean it's it's like map is like
a map over a partition oh so you want
something that's more like a the max
equivalent to analog to accumulate
that's correct but which is exactly what
we're doing with fold yeah yeah which is
correct there okay let's let's go on I
think we're we seem to be in I I
personally think we shouldn't bother
with the operator forms right now right
now so something is small in our life
stream it was suggested that we add can
write these of two months and six months
and you can I cannot come up with yeah I
mean I think the the six month set is
probably obviously semiannual
granularity but for either two months
sets or three months sets what about
five monthly what
does bi-monthly mean twice a month by
monthly technically means twice a month
okay I mean it's it's where we run into
the biannual versus biennial problem of
the two terms are so often confused okay
so what are we what does this go into
this is going into date object right yep
it's a granularity specification like
quarter or yeah yeah I mean I understand
why we want this and it's obviously
worthwhile so let's just come up with a
name um we use nouns not okay so we've
got here we've got well why don't we
call that half year half year and is the
only thing wrong with calling it half
year there's no problem with half year
and then would really say like third
year and sixth year for the four and two
months Bin's I mean they're not as
popularly used well is it but what is
the what is correct with respect to leap
years what does half year mean anyway I
mean yes all right so there's the notion
of so we have a split as always with
calendar units versus are more you know
pedantic definition of units where the
length of a month in the unit framework
is fixed but the length of a month is
different when you're using calendars
because it varies depending on how long
a month is right and so for the calendar
units we tend to use the we use the
definitions that are basically based on
the iterators used in the calendar so
semi-annually or half yearly would be
six month bins if it's you know so it
doesn't it doesn't miss a line if you
say this happens semi-annually
it'll happen on June 1st or whatever it
is and it won't it won't it won't sort
of wrap around as the leap years move
yes
if it happens before July first then
it's in the first half of the half-year
and if it happens after that it's in the
second half regardless of whether it is
a leap year the tricky case is for
Islamic and Jewish calendars which have
leap months and leap years but I tried
looking at I didn't find anything super
definitive on how they handle half-year
cases there it may just be something
where we say we have some default system
or don't use this granularity for these
two calendars I'm sure we can reach out
and find out the answer to that if there
is an answer I mean it may be that I
mean the real question will be I would
suspect things like financial
institutions and so on that would have
defined this hmm but sometimes they may
not exist in these cases for whatever
reason um okay so let's understand what
this is so what what is the request for
the request is for we've got quarters
which are three months mm-hmm
and the request was for six month chunks
and I believe the original request was
for two month chunks but we may also
want to have four months chunks so I
wonder whether we shouldn't just make it
less obscure and just say just have a
thing that says six months
[Music]
because I worry about if we say
half-year we're not saying quarter yeah
yeah there's an alternate name but what
we should do that but that way it's
pretty unambiguous um at least rigged
Orion and Julian calendars alright so
yeah in a particular six month bin
that's okay that's alright let's do it
okay okay
oh boy through the thread yes this was a
suggestion and very similar to head math
which were planning to change this
through applied to align it to with our
recent flight functions the fact that I
can't remember I mean I do remember what
head map does but the cup fact that I
can't remember what through thread does
there's a bad sign and the name is not
helping me very much but I think I'm not
sure there was an extra suggest you know
what implementation was I've new
suggested it was something like this
I've simplified it but suggestion was
just done yeah honestly that's short
enough that if one ever knew to do it
it's not clear that this helps home very
much I mean if you see that ink through
thread and code and you versus you see
an inner construct I'm not sure that Tim
that's really help
full um what about calling this like
zip-zip is too similar to thread I mean
and unfortunately zip who set the
standard meaning in other languages you
know there's a very complicated thing
because I named May I had a bunch of
naming that got used in other languages
and it was slightly different and you
know it's gotten very confused over the
years also there's the notion of zip for
compression so there that's gonna be
confusing
I can't imagine that zip is a good idea
for this it's a short name it's the same
mistake we made with names like through
because we thought that head operations
would be more common so to speak um I
mean I thought that 30-something years
ago and they may yet be back I mean they
they're you know I mean the problem is
the concept of a symbolic I don't know
how it works anymore
through of that right or is it that of X
yes that's what it is I like that
operation I mean it may yet you know by
the time we're doing currying all over
the place and so on we may yet end up
you know being happy about this but for
30 years this thing sort of languished
as being a pretty obscure thing
I think also that the concept of a of
using that which here right that the
through of this I mean why didn't that
work am I completely confused oh no no I
see I see I see this is what I want
that's what I want there okay so I don't
understand this this is the through
thread of this which instead of doing
this where it throughs everything
yes that's is a wonder through up light
which does what
effectively what you just did she's
taking out a bunch of a list of
functions and apply them all to see had
Maps had map yeah is the function it
would so what does head map do that's
different from through head map a list
of functions F G H oh I see I see I see
I see I see I see so this is the analog
so that will be through applied gosh is
obscure I mean
also very difficult to name and and when
we introduced the applied functions
Pareto applied etc we thought that
perhaps this was a way to come forth
through a black
yeah pointing back to through except
perhaps compounding the error through
his head applied an obviously bad name
what are the other applied functions now
there's reverse applied but it applied
carry applied and I think we haven't
introduced yet but stoplight okay so
reverse applied of f of X Y because that
so head applied would that mean the
right thing I think it gives the
impression that there is just a single
head well the main point here is that we
have you know well it is the right name
probably through applied given what
through does through applied is the
right name
question on a live stream is through
thread apply a map thread of construct I
do not know of what it would be a parent
of lists and the variables so matrix so
no another list of ABC and then one two
three but doesn't that need the map
thread doesn't it need that and list I'm
not able to read this ah help apply this
thing is going to be a map thread of
construct applied to this well
absolutely
we don't need e apply a bit removed
applying us in the Maps Redis should be
enough
that's magnificent
a good example for construct by the way
mm-hmm um I admit that this isn't you
know look through thread is such an
obscure name that it's not clear it's
any advantage of a map thread of
construct if we could get a better name
that would actually explain what it's
doing
well I think through thread is a
hopelessly obscure name and now looking
at this we can also transpose and then
trip a lot construct yes okay through
applied so this is a function that there
has appeared the number of times oh I
know I know I know I know I know this is
a function that again has had naming
problems
well the question is really is this form
is it primarily an operator form or is
it
I mean the problem is in this form it is
more like a backwards map so to speak
but in this form it's more like a star
applied type function oh boy
you know I for some reason I have this
vision of this must be like four or five
years ago now being at some airport
being in one of these design meetings
discussing this exact same function
we've discussed this many times um
I wish we just had a good yeah I'm not
I'm not seeing it again I mean I think
through applied is is a bit obscure um
let's can we just talk for a minute
about some by the way
Hosea on our livestream is pointing out
that the running max is one of the neat
examples and documentation from moving
map so we should check that another
question about any calendar input
browser UI I think there is something
coming therefore forms on the web at
least
not sure about that
of a user interface element in the front
end that's an interesting request and a
reasonable one I mean we were more
concerned about web forms immediately um
you
ah by the way Mohammed on the livestream
is asking about dataset and talking
about having a button to make it into a
blob that can be copied I think that is
coming in 12:1 a mechanism for doing
that
yes and I think also I mean by the way
one thing I this is kind of not the
right meeting but I might mention in any
way a thing that I've noticed that we
really would be useful is if I do a big
say I do a range of I don't know 10 to
the 5 or something and we get a too big
right I would like to turn this thing
into an ionized expression into a fully
downloaded I can eyes to expression if
you understand what I mean yeah I think
it has been suggested to add a button
there together with this show more show
all while it is just I can eyes you know
I think that's the right thing can we
make it happen I think it was suggested
already I will check with day ok
is that an atty problem or is that where
would that happen ok I want to talk
about string settings for number form
because this is driving me crazy right
so we have you know you want to I mean I
want to make numbers that are for
example let's do some examples here
let's say I go one point five point you
know numerical value but PI or something
well numerical value of pi whatever okay
now okay so there I get them done like
that but let's say I want to get that PI
formatted to two digit precision and
this thing also to two digits okay so I
say number form of that comma - oh it
did the right thing
well let's see what happens if I do
number form of that comma three
you
ah see that's not doing the right thing
because I want that to be able to give
me a 5-0 there if I'm trying to line
numbers up is there a way to do that I
think this was infinity comma 3
that's obscure that means that means no
no but that's not necessarily what I
want because maybe one of these numbers
okay so look a typical okay there's
another case that's very ugly okay so
let's say I say n of 7 times 10 to the
times 10 to the 12 or something okay
okay I get 7 points that's really ugly
how do I get rid of that point what
version of number form gets rid of that
point I think we have discussed the
possibility of having from number point
goes to automatic or going to 9 going to
well I mean you can do this look one way
to do it which is just completely
obscure is to say number point arrow
nothing okay that will do it but that's
really obscure the issue is like for
tables of numbers and things yeah I mean
I want some way of doing that I mean
again I think we need to inventory like
you did very beautifully for the plus
minus stuff with around I think we need
to inventory these different cases of
displaying numbers where you know
something like this arguably well I
don't know what's correct here I mean I
think seven point times down to 12 it's
nice it gives you that precision
indication
why's dat 7.000 times 10 to the 12 right
right yeah there isn't I mean old
Fortran and C there was this print F
specifications with G seven point nine
things at that and those were very
specific well right but they had I mean
that was a mantissa exponent deal but
that doesn't really help you here
because it doesn't really it doesn't
really help I see you're saying where
it's it's let me see I want to have if I
have in my table if I have this if I
have two numbers in my table okay I have
this and I have seven point four times
ten to twelve okay now for many purposes
you know if I'm putting these in a nice
elegant table I want that to say seven
times seven to twelve and seven point
four times ten to twelve
I don't want seven point times ten to
twelve I know what the second one to be
elided to seven times ten to the twelve
I'm saying
the first one should be 7.0 no well okay
that's a good question
it should either be 7.0 or it should be
7 I don't think you can I don't think
one can decide immediately between those
two I can imagine different cases but it
sure shouldn't be 7.2 that's useless
that's neither elegant nor informative
well it's a way of indicating that it's
not exact just how could it be exact you
can't get 7 times 10 to the 12 as an
exact number see 7 times 10 to the 12 in
our system wouldn't be an exact number
it would resolve right I don't even know
whether you can print 7 can you do that
can you can you write a number if I type
7 times 10 to 12 I'll get this
okay now with decimal form am I able to
get no the other way around there with
with scientific okay let's see if I say
scientific form of % 37 it doesn't work
some reals like like number form itself
see that seems wrong again
right I mean what we've got is a screwy
situation where if I if I end this I'll
get the seven-point unless I do the
number form you know number point hack
look I think what we should do is to
inventory the different cases of numbers
of which the ones that I'm aware of are
whether there's a point at all okay so
the issues that I know of whether the
the decimal point is displayed at all
whether a trailing down whether to
display the trailing decimal point
whether to put a point zero or point
more than one zero
um
no in a number what other cases I think
those are the main ones that I've run
into
upright
see I think the real thing one has to
think about of these sequences of
numbers where one needs consistency in
the sequence somehow I'm saying I think
number form was designed with respect to
individual numbers but I think what we
need to think about is you've got a
sequence of numbers how do you get
consistency between them right so for
example let's say we say table of you
know 3 over N and goes up to 12 or
something okay great
now we say n of that
see why do you I mean three point is
what we get to represent the fact that
it's a decimal number fine
gosh it's very unclear what we want to
get in all these cases
well there's not necessarily a single
answer here I know like for example what
I mean if I want five I think I can get
if I say number form percent forty let's
say I want five does that do that yes
that does that I think the case that I'm
most concerned about is that point case
how do we get rid of the point and one
way to do that would be to have a number
form here that says it isn't just for
one of these maybe it becomes automatic
or something we could certainly have a
number point goes automatic no no no but
III meant that one of these numbers
becomes automatic to indicate it isn't
quite right that's one of those numbers
but to indicate if it's if it is
consistent with an integer don't show
the point
but I agree number point goes to
automatic seems like a very obvious
thing to have
that's a minimal thing to have and I
think number point goes to automatic
should be the default for access labels
because having a three point on an axis
label is just silly okay
maybe it's a topic for a different time
but can we get with Bret maybe and ask
him to join one of these and let's talk
about that case but I think number point
goes to automatic and having that bit of
the fault pie axis labels are possibly
even also in traditional would be a good
idea okay now look at it okay but I
think also we need a again inventory the
different cases here particularly ask
Brett with respect to tick labeling all
right um oh we have a long comment here
um I need to get my lunch this is uh I
am failing through like a food um just
to be clear I mean a summary blob where
the data set stops
explains content but turns into blob
like sparse array oh I see
I see so so basically what you're asking
for is an icon eyes of a data set if I'm
understanding correctly so in other
words if I say data set of this and it
has a big display on the screen the idea
would be to have something what happens
if I just say if I just select that and
say oh wow what is that doing why
doesn't that have the standard right
click menu oh it does have a snow right
click now okay and I say I can eyes that
data set so why would that not I mean
being able to have a little bit more
detail in the icon in the ionized form
that would be nice but why doesn't that
serve what you need um well anyway bit
but that's another suggestion is for a
structure like data set I mean it
doesn't don't we for a list what I just
do here what was this I must have done
something different there but don't be
for a list if I I can eyes a list yeah
we do give the head and the length and
so on whereas for data set we're just
giving the byte count so that's probably
a mistake does that make sense yeah we
for mission there that's I think that
would be useful how many islands there
are and so on rather than just the byte
count um so I think that at least does
part of what we need um good ok talk to
you all soon
thanks thanks guys on the live stream -
we'll be back in due course see ya